this is my picture of the week Berlin's
landmark the Brandenburg Gate is
illuminated in the blood-red of the
Turkish flag following the attack on
Istanbul on New Year's Eve this
projection epitomizes the sense of
solidarity felt in Germany for turkey
two countries which have been linked
with each other for a very long time
we've seen the Brandenburg Gate light up
in different colors in the past year
France Belgium this seems like yet
another episode in some kind of mccobb
installation but this time it is
different whether you like it or not the
turkish kebab belongs to germany as much
as sour crab does there is a deep bond
between Germans and Turks a friendship
one that defies eight and violence and
that's what this picture is all about
millions of Turks are firmly rooted in
this society their pain is Germany's
pain these people they came here with
nothing but hope for a better life I
know them well my family is one of them
most jerks who traveled to Germany may
well have found what they were looking
for but they've also had to stay behind
watching from a distance as this long
string of attacks has devastated Turkey
this flag illuminating the Brandenburg
Gate the Turkish flag was deliberately
designed to look this way the red
symbolizes the blood of those who have
to give their lives in defense of the
Republic when will this flag finally be
read enough
[Music]